xqc has been permaban from the gta 5
role-playing server no pixel his
behavior on there has often been
criticized but his streams have brought
a
ton of new viewers to the server and to
gta 5 role playing in general
let's break down what exactly led to the
ban and what's next for no pixel
[Music]
alright guys just before we get into
this make sure you are subscribed to the
score esports if you haven't done so
already
that way you'll never miss a story like
this or any of our other great videos on
this channel
now for those of you that don't know gta
5 has recently
exploded on twitch thanks in large part
to xqc
and one role playing server in
particular no pixel
the server is full of role players
acting out every kind of real world job
you can think of
from fast food workers to lawyers tough
cops to harden
criminals it doesn't really matter what
you choose to do in this world but you
must stick to the rules and remain
in character otherwise the whole
role-playing world just kind of breaks
down
now no pixel has been quietly doing its
thing since 2018 but
since xqc started playing on the server
it's exploded in popularity
and that popularity has spread to
smaller streamers who have benefited
from xqc playing on the server
you know does xqcd rule breaks yeah is
he learning yeah
is he a slow learner yeah but
at the end of the day you have multiple
people that's been role playing for a
long time
that have built careers on it and you
have people whose lives have changed
drastically where they can do what they
love every day
instead of having to go to do another
job because of people like him
and people like summit that give
exposure to the server since joining no
pixel
xqc has never shied away from the
criminal life
and has had plenty of run-ins with the
police
usually as he tries to drive their car
off the pier to
feed the kraken and send it
unfortunately though he's also had
run-ins with the server's admins last
month we covered how xqc got banned for
using a glitch to kill police officers
while in jail
he was eventually unbanned and since
then xqc
has been playing a lot of no pixel
pulling
back to back 100 hour weeks and
regularly reaching over 100 000
concurrent viewers
this guy did 100 back to back weeks
are you serious how am i supposed to get
number one for one [ __ ] week with
this
psychopath out here what is he doing
get a hobby but april 3rd could prove to
have been
xqc's last stream on no pixel and here's
how it all went down
he got 224 months in jail after robbing
a car
while on parole outside of the police
department
uh you're looking at uh 224 months
wait how many months 224.
uh don't assist don't do this please
don't do this
while being led to a cell xqc told the
police officer that he hoped he died
which led to a lot of heated debate
within the no pixel community about
whether or not this was out of character
you're a hypocrite
piece of [ __ ] thank you thank you sir
appreciate it i hope you can die thank
you sir
then when some of his viewers suggested
chat hopping to the officer's stream in
order to
argue his case for him xqc didn't tell
them to do it
but he didn't exactly discourage them
either so
thank god okay encouraging chat hopping
is a big no-no by the way when streaming
on no pixel
while in prison xqc reacted to the
criticism about the chat hopping that
had occurred
people think that hoppers that discredit
all possible criticism if somebody's
being a stupid idiot
and they'll just say yo dude that's kind
of stuff and hopper's safe
dude that's what yeah they shouldn't be
hopping it but this doesn't make it
immune from criticism they're not
invincible because there's hoppers
before long he was free and decided to
take on a new joker arc for his
character
john paul one that truly gave no [ __ ]
about the law
after shooting another officer during a
police chase xqc
was angry to find out that the downed
officer had told his colleague
that it was xqc who shot him which led
to him being arrested again
wait this guy is metagaming while dead
what the f what is wrong with him
when you're down in no pixel you can
essentially role play as
dead unconscious conscious or anywhere
in between
xqc was pissed off because he felt like
the cop
would not have been able to identify him
because he was wearing a helmet
the windscreen was all smashed up and
he'd shot the cop
about five or six times in the head and
it's here where following the rules of
rping in no pixel
can get a little blurred by claiming
that the cop was meta gaming
xqc argued that the cop wasn't role
playing
fairly and therefore breaking the rules
of the server
soon after that xqc pulled a gun on
officer wrangler played by streamer
penta and demanded he meet him to return
the items taken from him
okay listen just calm down just tell me
what you want for
sake okay three lock picks one phone a
thousand bucks xqc waited in jail once
again watching clips of the officers
talking about him but when he returned
to the game
he found the all too familiar band
screen although the band
said it would be permanent a message
from the admins
also said they would be reaching out to
him so at the moment
we don't know for sure if xqc is banned
forever from no pixel
xqc tweeted out saying that he was sorry
for his trashy mood
and that he got unreasonably mad he also
asked for people to not spread hate on
anyone and what he says
isn't always true in the aftermath some
streamers such as summit did seem
sympathetic
towards xqc i feel like there's a line
there it's like you can i can say
that yo charles wants to this cop but
what can i do i can shoot a cop he goes
down for 15 minutes what you can do
is because your character gets mad you
can someone for two hours that was
already in for two hours
and i feel like that is no possible way
that that's only character
there has to be some ooc involved there
now xqc isn't the only person who's been
hit with a permanent ban on no pixel
back in march streamer train wrecks was
permanently banned from no pixel
after he was accused of meta gaming
essentially train wrecks was using
information that his character wouldn't
realistically have
access to in order to gain an unfair
advantage
which as you can tell because he got
banned from it is a big violation of no
pixels rules
he eventually released a whole twit
longer about all of this in which he
really went
in on some elements of the no pixel
community here's the thing you need to
understand
no pixel is an entire living breathing
world
there are countless complex
relationships and storylines that are
ever changing as people play on the
server
now that's what makes it so appealing to
watch but it also makes it quite
difficult to sum up in a nutshell
it might seem like no pixel has a lot of
arbitrary rules but these rules
are important for the role playing to
work successfully so all of xqc's antics
and subsequent bans
is indicative of this tug of war between
xqc's unique brand of
chaos and this role-playing machine
that's trying to deal with it but at the
end of the day no pixel
has grown because of xqc and brought in
new viewers
which is something that hassan alluded
to after xqc got banned
he is a great entry point in the role
play for a lot of people
because he does yeah popcorn role play
exactly so
does xqc deserve the ban well that's up
for you to decide some of you
may have formed your opinions on xqc or
the current situation
long before you clicked on this video
just like last time
xqc got banned we don't have a concrete
reason from no pixel
about why it happened it could be due to
the chat hopping incident we talked
about earlier or it could be due to
wishing that cop would die if it was
deemed that he said it out of character
either way if he ever does return to no
pixel you can expect more 20-hour
streams
more viewers watching him battle it out
with the police and the buzz around him
will undoubtedly continue
people watch and talk about xqc no
matter how they actually
feel about him and nobody understands
that more than xqc himself
no one can something it was a pure dog
[ __ ] it was really bad
but everybody was watching it though
because i don't get what people say
something is dog [ __ ] but they all watch
it i'm so confused by it
it's like a car crash but we can't look
away
before long he was free and decided to
take on
a new joker arc for his character jean
paul
john paul for his character john paul
character john why am i saying john say
the [ __ ] word john
jesus john paul i'm trying to say it
like jean and john at the same time
for his character john what what am i
doing
john why can't i say john john paul
just start listing the beatles and go
from there it's easy
oh god xqc is definitely going to react
to this video as well